[Music]
studio xml is conceptualized to be a
progressive project it hopes to archive
and document the journeys and stories of
singapore designers before they shine
and before they die creating a
comprehensive volume of singapore design
history that can be assessed by current
and future generations of students
designers and everyone who loves design
and wants to have an understanding of
what designers do
in this slide studio sml takes on the
role of a vessel that shares knowledge
and teachings much like a sage the wise
one
conceived during a pandemic i hope that
the stories in studio sml can inspire
and be a source of reflection for our
design community
to provide respite and recharge for the
creative mind during these strange times
produced in a time of adversity much
like the spirit of most designers who
often thrive despite hardships studio
xml embodies the same spirit of sage the
hub
[Music]
abstract creatures is an art
installation launching the website
studios.net
abstract creatures is a metaphor for
design studios as designers often run
their studios organically without any
business plans or buy the book
strategies
development of the studio and business
is often done intuitively and
spontaneously each studio is like an
abstract creature something strange
something intriguing something that has
a life of its own
just like lalang grass they grow and
spread without the need for any external
help
what we have here is a flying elephant
it's a little bit inspired by dumbo and
it's a metaphor for chang yongdae who is
from chiang architects he's a one-man
show small studio why he's a flying
elephant is because yonte as we know
is a great designer and his designs are
always very majestic but yongtan as a
person is very very quiet very gentle
always very humble but yet his presence
is always felt
this was actually the first design that
i did that inspired this whole
exhibition when i was thinking of studio
sml as an entity i was thinking what is
common to all design studios it dawned
upon me that through the interviews that
we did every design studio sort of grew
organically without a real business plan
so each studio is like an abstract
creature so with that metaphor i
designed this first mythical creature it
doesn't look like anything because it
shouldn't it's actually inspired by this
chinese idiom shantholiopi which
literally translates as three hates six
legs
and it is a mythical creature but it
really means a maverick in chinese randy
is an old friend and he's a very diverse
creations are always very very
surprising to me he is kind of like a
maverick that cannot be described he's a
santolio p which is a three hit six
limbs
[Music]
so this is the metaphor for xinshank
jessica and pam
is actually a pair of atlantic puffins
pam and jessica are good friends of mine
and they seem to be so in sync with each
other they could even complete each
other's sentences off but at the same
time they besides apart from their
business they live very very separate
lives
so
why the atlantic puffin is because
puffins they usually lead their own
lives and they come together once a year
to meet
so i thought it's the perfect metaphor
for seeing pam and jessica because they
live separate lives but they live for
sing shang and they came together for
this venture which is their baby
[Music]
this is uh ecoid architects the two
partners are kelvin and bun young they
are a large firm of 70 to 80 people
their
metaphor is roofs basically wolves like
to move in packs so they have you know
sort of like a big pack of wolves with
them and wolves also like to explore new
territories and for them they have
offices all over the region they're
really the rules of architecture
[Music]
so this cute little one
is a metaphor for gabriel tan his
metaphor is a cross between a cockroach
and a grasshopper
[Music]
as i know him is one of the most
hard-working designers he is a person
with a lot of great never say die and
would do anything to make things happen
hence a cockroach which will never even
die in a nuclear war and that's gabriel
for you and why a grasshopper as well
because gabriel is now based in portugal
so he has kind of like lived out of his
comfort zone from singapore to to
portugal a place that he's totally not
familiar with
[Music]
to be a successful designer is not
something that happens overnight
and more often than not the journey is
not an easy one
besides having to go through the same
hardships as any startups you also have
to stay inspired and creative amidst
running the business
every day you go to work every day you
are like creeper scaling the wall one
millimeter one centimeter you hardly
notice it but you're scaling higher very
slowly every day
[Music]
every day you come back from a tired day
of work
you deserve to rest and if you can just
do a little bit of things that make you
happy
be doodling eating something nice a walk
in the park
learn to appreciate these little moments
because this is happiness at its purest
and simplest form
the chinese violet is called yelaisyang
and it translates as fragrance by night
a little bit of fragrance by night is
what the chinese violet works so hard
for every day
and that perhaps
is bliss
[Music]
you